know I think after 20 years of hearing
no and not getting that big yes it wears
on you you know and I got very depressed
and I remember I auditioned for this big
screen test role and it didn't happen
and so to be honest I was in bed for
three months I was like you know what
I'm not doing this anymore I just need
to take a break and I know the saying is
you know just keep hustling keep going
but I think sometimes you just need to
pause so I'm so glad that I took my
pause I took my break I reassessed I
said you know what I love this too much
to say no forever so let me just get
back on the horse and do it and I'm so
glad because Ghost came and it's the
biggest blessing of my life